The Lunar New Year has typically been called the Chinese New Year.
That's not wrong and it's not right.
There's a whole another group of Asian countries...
...that also celebrate based on the lunar calendar.
They're really warding off the evil spirits,...
...which is the intention of the dance:...
...to get rid of all the evil things that have happened in the year before...
...and to welcome boldly the new year.
They're not meant to be a lot of money.
It sort of helps people say, "You're part of my life."
If you do present a red envelope, make sure you do it with two hands...
...and that you use new bills...
...because you don't wanna put a ratty five-dollar bill in a red envelope.
That would not be a good idea.
Red is supposed to be prosperity, health,...
...so if you ever went to a Chinese New Year dinner...
...and you're wearing white or black, you should just go home and change.
A lot of the celebratory components center on food, a lot of food.